- Some of the things that
I like to remind people,
is we're the 28th
largest state population,
19th largest land-area wise.
We've got some of
the cleanest water,
cleanest air in the country.
We have an all-of-the-above
approach in energy.
In other words, we
love oil and gas.
We're number six
in oil production,
number four in natural gas,
but we're also number two
in wind energy production.
So we're one of
only four states,
four states that 40% of our
energy comes from renewables.
And so it's very attractive to
a lot of companies right now.
(soft music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and as you guys know,
I'm off the grid
for all of August,
but we pre-taped a bunch
of interviews for you
before I left the internet.
And joining me today is
the governor of Oklahoma,
Governor Kevin Stitt,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Hey, great to be with
you, thanks so much.
Hope you're having a great
time on your vacation
when this is airing.
- I hope that I'm
having a great time too,
not paying attention
to the news,
but I am looking forward
to chatting with you
because we met a couple weeks
before I went off the grid.
Governor DeSantis held a
little event in Florida
for some governors and
some Twitter personalities
or whatever the rest of us are.
And you brought up a
couple interesting points
and I immediately
went up to you after,
I said, "We gotta chat."
So here we are.
So before we do anything,
you know, people
talk about Oklahoma
and most people probably say,
"Hey, what's going
on in Oklahoma?
I don't know much
about Oklahoma."
So first, why don't
we just get a little
of your personal history?
And then we'll dive
into some of the stuff
we need to know about Oklahoma.
- Absolutely. Well,
I'm the 28th governor
of the great state of Oklahoma,
fourth generation Oklahoman,
and a business guy.
I was never in politics
when I ran in 2018.
My story, I grew up
in Norman, Oklahoma,
where the University
of Oklahoma is.
My dad was a pastor
there and then-
But I went to Oklahoma state
in Stillwater for college,
got an Accounting degree,
and then started my company
shortly after college
with a thousand
dollars and a computer
and lived the
American dream story.
Today we have 1,600 employees,
do business all
over the country.
And I got inspired to run,
I watched a
businessman get elected
President of the United States,
and I saw my state
kind of struggling
and I looked and
saw who was running,
it was just more of
the same, really,
just career politicians.
And I said, "Hey, if
anything's gonna change,
we need business people.
We need a fresh set of eyes.
We need people like our
founding fathers envision
that were gonna leave
the private sector,
go serve their country
or their state,
and actually change
things and focus
on the next generation,
not the next election."
And so I told that to
Oklahomans when I campaigned,
they agreed with me.
We won the election and today,
Oklahoma is really
exploding in growth.
We have so many
great things going.
We've got the largest savings
account we've ever had,
we have the lowest unemployment,
I cut taxes last year,
more people are moving to
Oklahoma than ever before.
We're top 10 in the
country in that.
And so things are just
really on the up and up
for our state.
We're the 28th largest
state population-wise,
right above Texas figuratively
and actually right above Texas,
so I like to point that out.
- So I think a lot of
people watching this
are probably going,
"Wait a minute, Oklahoma?
It can't have that many problems
that a successful
business guy has to run."
I mean, we talk about
California's problems,
we talk about New
York's problems,
maybe Illinois's
problems, I mean,
mostly blue state problems.
What could possibly be
going on in Oklahoma
that a successful guy,
I mean, you were running
multimillion dollar business,
would have to throw
his hat in the ring?
- Well, what I'm talking about,
we had a teacher
walkout, for example.
We weren't paying our
teachers what market was.
So I gave our
teachers a pay raise
to bring 'em up to market.
Government won't fix itself,
government always
wants to spend more.
So bringing that
fiscal discipline,
I believe in smaller government,
I believe in lower taxes.
So bringing some of
those disciplines
into our state budget
and running government
like a business,
is kind of what I focused on.
There's 33,000 state
employees in Oklahoma.
It's a $22 billion budget.
And normally people
hire non-business people
and people that have
never signed paychecks,
never set a vision, and
hired the right people,
held people accountable.
So those are all the things
that we brought to Oklahoma.
And so things are
moving the needle,
we've deregulated our business,
setting a level playing field,
not picking winners and losers.
So people understand, you know,
the great things about
moving to our state.
Energy policy, we have
an all-of-the-above
energy approach,
and that's led to the
lowest cost of electricity
to a business or consumer.
So keeping those
conservative values going,
even in a red state like ours,
sometimes the bureaucracy
and the government
can get away from you,
and you've gotta come
in with an outsider
to bring it back in check.
- I heard you talk a bit
about this a couple weeks ago,
but how did you deal with
all the lockdown madness,
and figuring out what
to do and allowing,
or not allowing people to
live their lives accordingly?
- Well, you know,
first off, we believe
in freedoms in Oklahoma.
And we believe in
our Constitution,
and we're not gonna put our
Constitution in the attic,
just because somebody
in Washington DC
says that we should do that.
You know? So we kept our
state open the entire time.
I kept our schools open.
I wasn't going to say
this business is essential
and this business
is not essential.
The only non-essential
business is one
that you didn't put capital in,
or you don't get
your paycheck from.
So picking winners
and losers like that
to me is un-American,
it's not right,
and what we've done
to our businesses,
and then what we did to our kids
by keeping 'em outta school
in these other states,
it's an atrocity.
So in Oklahoma, we
kept everything open.
And because of that now,
people are realizing and
recognizing the benefits,
our businesses are having
their best years ever,
and companies from California
are moving to states like ours,
because they're
tired of the mandates
and the dictating from
the holier-than-thou
government officials
that we know best,
and do as we say.
- So I think everyone
watching knows my story.
And you heard it at
that event we did.
I am a new Floridian, about
seven months in right now,
after living in California.
And you mentioned you guys
are getting this influx
of people and businesses.
Does that worry you ever?
That you know, these
businesses come in,
they bring a whole
bunch of people,
they've often voted
the wrong way,
which caused the problems
in the first place,
and now they have to
integrate into a new state
that is basically
doing it right?
- You know, we hear that a lot.
The folks that we meet
from California, you know,
I have those
conversations with 'em.
I jokingly tell 'em, "Hey,
I had to wait 18 years
to vote in Oklahoma, so I
expect you to wait 18 years
before you can vote."
But they say, they go, "Hey,
listen, here's the deal.
There's 12 million
people in California
that voted for president Trump.
The people that are leaving
are recognizing the differences
between a blue state
and a red state."
And so trust me, they're
saying, "We are on your side.
We believe in freedoms. We
believe in smaller government.
We believe in less regulation."
Doing business in California
is an absolute beat down.
I know that personally, and
from the regulatory climate,
from the taxation climate,
they're just so outta touch
with what our values are
as Oklahomans and
most of Americans
that I think normal
people are leaving there.
- Before we jump into
some of the specifics,
what else do people have
to know about Oklahoma?
I feel like it's just
like one of those states
that people kind of,
they go through it,
they maybe fly over it,
and they don't think
about it that much,
but you guys are
doing an awful lot
when it comes to energy
and a whole bunch more.
- Yeah. Well, I mean, I was
just in Farmborough, England,
representing our state
for the aerospace
and defense industry.
And some of the things that
I like to remind people is,
we're the 28th largest
state population,
19th largest land area-wise.
We've got some of
the cleanest water,
cleanest air in the country.
We have an all-of-the-above
approach and energy,
in other words, we
love oil and gas.
We're number six
in oil production,
number four in natural gas,
but we're also number two
in wind energy production.
So we're one of
only four states,
four states that 40% of our
energy comes from renewables.
And so it's very attractive to
a lot of companies right now,
but we have the largest
maintenance and repair facility
on aviation in the country,
with Tinker Air Force Base,
so great aviation industry.
We've got an inland port.
So most people don't
realize that about Oklahoma.
We have the farthest frost
free port in the country,
all the way almost to Tulsa.
So a lot of great things going,
we got great agriculture,
we feed the world
in a lot of cases
from our agricultural side,
number two beef
producer in the country.
So a lot of great things going.
And then the freedoms.
Oklahoma City, I think
is the 25th largest city
in the country.
We've got the funder of
professional sports team.
So the quality of life,
the commute in Oklahoma
is like 15 minutes
compared to an hour in some of
the other major metro areas.
So people love the
quality of life.
You gotta come visit Oklahoma.
- And I'm guessing house prices
a little bit better than
here in Florida right now.
- Definitely right.
I mean, we obviously
are, you know,
everything's going up
all over the country,
but we've got an
arbitrage right now.
And that's what
businesses are seeing,
is that they can come in
and the quality of life
with the cost of living,
allows them to pay less than
you can on some of the coast.
And with COVID, you're seeing
people move and saying,
"I don't have to work
in this big city,
or through technology
we can live anywhere,"
but we're also seeing
headquarters move
to Dallas, Fort Worth,
and move to Oklahoma City
and move to other states
and get out of the
New York City areas
or the bay areas
where crime is rampant
and homelessness
and all the stuff
that doesn't happen
in our state.
- You mentioned the amount of
oil and gas you guys produce,
and then also wind power.
Does that cause any tension
in the business community
or any tension with
the federal government?
Because the federal
government at least,
seems to view oil
and gas versus wind
as very, very different things.
They like one, they
don't like the other.
- You know, that's the
thing that blows their mind
whenever I go and meet with
the Biden administration
and their secretary of energy,
and we talk about
it all the time.
Those things can
coexist together.
We believe in the free
market in Oklahoma,
we believe in an
all-of-the-above approach.
So they do coexist just fine.
We love our oil
and gas industry,
and you can't have
an intellectually
honest conversation
about the needs of Americans
and a reliable energy grid
without talking about natural
gas and talking about oil,
but we don't shy away.
We're leaning into
hydrogen, for example.
I signed an MOU
with the governor of
Arkansas and Louisiana,
we believe that we will get
one of the four hydrogen hubs
to prove out it's a $2
billion kind of program
to prove out a commercialization
use of hydrogen,
but you're gonna need pipelines
for hydrogen development.
We can coexist together, and
you can talk about transition,
and you can talk
about oil and gas.
And again, we don't know
why there's such an attack
on the oil and gas industry
from this administration,
because what's
their alternative?
Is to buy oil from
Russia or Saudi Arabia,
because demand is the same.
And here's something that I'd
like to point out to people.
Every president of the
United States, since 1973,
has had an energy
independence policy,
whether they were
Republican or Democrat
until this administration.
And they wanted to
just cancel everything,
cancel the Keystone Pipeline,
make drilling impossible,
but what they forget is, we
still have to drive to work,
we have to heat our
homes, our businesses,
we have to drive our
kids to soccer practice,
and football practice.
And so the demand is the same.
And they're not being honest.
- Do you think they-
Yeah, well that I
think is the part.
Do you think that they actually
are just simply not being honest
or this is by design that
they know people have
to go to work, they know
people have to get in the car,
but they are sort of telling us,
"Hey, we want off this stuff
regardless of the
repercussions."
- You know, I hope
that's not the case,
but I've seen the
reports just like you
that they make these
statements like, "Well,
we knew that prices were gonna
be jacked up for a while,
but that's gonna be
part of the process
to get off of oil and gas."
And I hope that's not true,
because to harm Oklahomans
or to harm Americans,
just because you have some
kind of left-wing agenda,
that's not the president
that I would hope
would be representing
our country.
But, you know, I don't
know what's happening,
because it doesn't make
common sense to most Americans
on why they're burying
their head in the sand
and not having an
honest conversation
when just a couple years ago,
we were energy independent.
And you're now seeing
inflation skyrocket,
everything costs more,
40-year highs at everything.
And actually they're
harming the people
that they actually think
that they're protecting.
That's what people
need to understand,
is these policies from
the Democratic party,
actually hurt average
Oklahoma, middle-income people.
The rich get richer and it
hurts everyday Oklahomans.
It's the Republicans,
it's a free market,
it's the innovation of business
that actually helps
the middle class grow.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
You're preaching to
the choir over here.
My audience gets it.
Anything else we should
know broadly about Oklahoma
before I wanna dive
into some of this stuff
that I heard you talking about,
about what's going on
with the Native American
reservations there,
which is really fascinating,
but anything else you wanna
get off your chest quick?
- Yeah, no, I'm good, I'm good.
- You're good?
- I'll probably
be circling back to it.
- Okay. So when I heard you
speak a couple weeks ago,
you told a really
fascinating story
and was describing
some of the tension
that Oklahoma faces
over what's going on
with the Native American
reservations there,
and how there is seemingly
a disparate distance
in the way laws
are being applied
when it comes to Native
American population
versus the average Oklahoman.
You told a couple
anecdotes about that,
can you just kind of
gimme the 101 on that?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Well, first off, the
McGirt decision came out
in July of 2020, and
basically what it said,
it was the US Supreme Court
decision called McGirt.
So I'll encourage
everybody to look it up,
but basically it said that
we still had reservations
in Oklahoma.
So about half of our state was
all of a sudden turned back
into an Indian reservation.
Tulsa, Oklahoma, with
a million people,
was now considered an
Indian reservation.
And here's the deal, I'm
not against the Indians.
I'm actually a member
of the Cherokee.
We're proud of our heritage.
- Right.
You literally, you yourself.
- Literally, I can
show you my card.
My heritage, I
have Indian blood.
So I have a membership
to the Indian,
to the Cherokee Nation.
So it's not an
anti-Indian thing,
but this is a
pro-Oklahoma thing,
this is a common sense thing.
So what was happening is we
had tribal governments then
saying that they
didn't have to follow
the laws of the
state of Oklahoma.
They were saying that, no,
that if you were Indian,
you didn't have to
pay taxes in Oklahoma,
but every other race did.
They were saying that
the district attorneys
couldn't prosecute
crimes the same way.
So you had a situation that
you didn't have fairness,
you didn't have equal
protection under the law.
And so I fought like crazy
against all odds, really,
because they're super powerful.
They're using taxpayer dollars
to get in and influence races
and try to run negative
ads against you,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I got a case back to
the Supreme Court and said,
"Listen, we have to
be able to prosecute,
to protect public safety,
all crimes in Eastern Oklahoma."
And Castro-Huerta
case just came out
since we talked, I believe,
that gave us a huge win.
And they said, "Yes,
you do have the right
to prosecute all
crimes in Oklahoma."
And furthermore, they said
that Indian reservations
are still part of a
state and therefore
they're subject to
state jurisdiction,
which gives us a lot
more certainty now
than we had once before.
So those are all
things that I think
Americans need to be aware of,
because this would be
like the Supreme Court
coming into your city and
your state and saying,
"Hey, this used to
be Indian land."
And so you no longer
have to follow,
they don't have to follow
zoning or taxation laws,
you know, those kind of things.
That's how it threw us into
kind of turmoil in our state.
- Yeah. Well, I would imagine
that the average citizen,
after the McGirt
decision, probably,
it increased tension actually
between the communities, right?
I mean, if you're just
the law abiding citizen
and now someone
breaks into your house
or whatever it might be,
and then they're not
gonna be prosecuted
because of their lineage,
I could see some
tension developing.
- A hundred percent. I mean,
we had district attorneys
telling people that if you
have an Indian tag on your car,
you need to park in the garage,
because there were people
targeting those people
because they knew that the state
couldn't prosecute those crimes.
So it was just ridiculous.
I mean, the 911 calls
going into our 911 system,
they were having to
ask the question,
"Well, are you native or not?"
And people were like, "Well,
do I have to tell you
if I'm native or not?
'Cause then you won't come out."
And so it was all this turmoil
and I'm glad that the Supreme
Court did the right thing
to say, "Hey, this
is still a state.
We have to be on equal footing
with every other state.
We have to be able
to regulate business
and oil, and gas, and
zoning, and mining,
and all the things
we can't turn that on
to county by county,
depending on, you know,
what Indian tribe used
to be located there.
- How was that for you,
with your background
having to go in and do
something that I'm sure
a certain amount
of people thought
you were a turn code or
there's probably words for it
that we need not
mention on this show?
- Yeah. You know, here's
what I tell people.
I said 95% of Native Americans
like me that have part native
blood, we're proud of that,
but we're American and
we're Oklahoma first.
So they actually agreed with me.
It was only those at the
very top of the tribe,
the big bosses that
were really fighting us
and putting money against us.
One tribe said they
were gonna stop flying
the Oklahoma flag on their land,
which then the citizens
really revolted,
and he quickly changed his tune.
That chief did like two
days later and said,
"Oh, okay, well I decided
I would keep flying
the Oklahoma flag."
So they took it too far.
And, you know, things
have a tendency
if pendulum swings too far,
people go, "Hey, this
doesn't feel right."
And it comes kind
of back to balance
and we believe that's
why the Supreme Court
brought that case back.
- Let me ask you as
a Native American,
that means automatically
you have to represent
all Native Americans.
How do you feel about, you know,
when they have
the Atlanta Braves
or the Washington Redskins?
You know, it usually
seems like it's a bit
of a media construct,
but obviously everyone
has their own feelings.
- Oh, listen,
we're so sensitive.
It doesn't bother me a bit.
Every single person like me,
10% of Oklahoma's population
are native, about 400,000.
And, you know, I think the
media blows out of proportion.
It's just like anything, it's
a very small vocal minority,
and what's disappointing
is these businesses
and these professional
teams just end up caving,
for, you know, a very
small vocal minority.
And I know that's kind
of where we're at today,
but I think the
bigger point to me is
we believe in America
and based on your merit,
and your hard work,
and your education, and
how hard you wanna work
depends on your success.
Not the color of your
skin or your nationality.
I want a system that
is fair for everybody
and doesn't pick
winners and losers.
And I think when we
try to pay people off,
or give money to this race,
or try to quote on quote,
"Right this wrong", I think
those are bad precedents,
and it'll end up
breaking our country
and it divides us further.
- Do you sense we're divided
sort of in an
irreparable fashion?
I mean, when you
talk about freedom
and capitalism and
limited government
and all those things that, yeah.
That's happening in red
states, it really is.
It seems to be strengthening
in certain states.
Certainly the two
states that we're in,
but it's not happening
in blue states.
And it doesn't seem like
it's gonna turn around
in blue states.
What do you think about
that tension going forward
as the United States of America?
- You know, I mean that's
the million dollar question.
You know, you look
back to our leaders
like Ronald Reagan and it felt
like he could bring
people together
and kind of talk
about capitalism
and the exceptionalism
of America
in a way that kind of
brought us together
and revitalized our country.
And so we hope that
we can get back there,
because I believe that
the majority of Americans
think like I do.
We believe in God.
And I think you take
God out of the values,
and we believe in-
We were founded our country
on these biblical values,
we believe in
freedom of religion.
That means we don't discriminate
against any religion,
but we certainly
don't discriminate it.
We can't discriminate against
the Christian faith either.
And so I think that most
people believe in family,
and capitalism, and
you have to work hard
and let's create a
level playing field
for everybody to go succeed.
And it's just disappointing
when some people think
that the answer is
government handouts,
and they think
that the answer is
more government and more taxes.
That's just, you can
look across history,
you can look at other countries
that have tried that model,
and I think that's failing.
But I still believe that
the majority of Americans
think like we do.
So if we say this
in a correct way,
I believe that's
the winning message.
- Yeah. I'm with you.
How have you guys
done when it comes
to all of the woke stuff?
Keeping the gender stuff and
the critical race theory,
all of that out of the schools,
or has it seeped in and
what are you doing about it?
- You know, again, sometimes
it tries to seep in.
What I've done about it is I,
as the first governor in the
country that passed the bill
that bans critical race theory,
and the media kind of calls
it critical race theory,
but here's all my bill said.
It just simply said that
in our school system,
we're not gonna teach
that one race or one sex
is superior to another
race or another sex.
That's all it says.
And I don't know how
you can argue, huh?
- Old school.
- The old school. How
can you argue with that?
Let's teach our kids,
not indoctrinate 'em
and teach 'em that
they're inferior
because of the
color of their skin,
or they're somehow responsible
for something that happened
a hundred years ago.
I'm not gonna teach
that to a first grader.
That's ridiculous.
And so I also signed the
Save Women in Sport Bill.
Which to us in Oklahoma, I mean,
we don't know what's going on
with the rest of the country,
because for us, it's like
everybody applauds me
that we're gonna
protect women's sports
and athletics and girls are
gonna play in girls sports,
and boys are gonna
play in boys sports.
I'm not gonna let
a biological male
compete in high school
against a female
that's been training
her whole life
where he has physical
advantages on the track
or in the swimming
pool against that girl.
And it doesn't make
sense to us in Oklahoma,
so it's easy for me to
sign these kind of bills.
- Is there any pushback
on that stuff in Oklahoma?
You get anything?
- I mean, you get some,
the whacked out folks,
but it's a very
small minority here.
- Yeah. What else is going on
since you're talking
so much about business,
and that really is
your background,
and you've mentioned this
sort of low, you know,
less regulation and
that sort of thing.
What else is going on
in the business world?
If someone's watching
this in Cali right now,
and they're thinking
about getting out
and I get emails every day from
Cali people on the way out,
and I'm usually selling
them on Florida,
but if they wanna stop
before they get here
and see what's going on?
- You gotta stop.
I mean, listen, Florida's second
place compared to Oklahoma.
Okay? You might have a
little bit of the ocean,
but if you wanna make
money and you wanna be...
And you want the
quality of life,
Oklahoma is the
right spot to be.
But, you know, technology
companies were going hard after.
I'm looking at where the
research and development dollars
are headed, where
we just sent Atlanta
a huge, huge electric
vehicle manufacturer
were going after
that supply chain,
around electric vehicles.
We have more electric
vehicle charging stations
per capita than any other state,
level-three charging stations.
So we're leaning
into that stuff.
Most people go, "Well,
Oklahoma's just oil and gas,"
simply not true.
I mean, we love our oil and gas,
and we are making sure
that we do our part
for our country on
oil and gas side,
but we're also not naive to
where the R&D
dollars are headed.
They're not in combustible
engines anymore,
they're in electric vehicles.
So we are all in there.
We're going into hydrogen,
we are looking at
that transition
and what type of other
energy sources can we have.
And as California's
having rolling blackouts,
we have the cheapest
electricity costs
to the business in the country.
- Yeah. It's nice to hear things
are going right sometimes.
Right? I mean, so what
are your headaches then?
I mean, what are
really the headaches?
You're giving me a pretty
rosy picture of state,
and you seem like things
are pretty sensible there
and all that stuff, you must
have a couple headaches.
- Well, I've got a
couple teenage daughters.
So if you could help me,
I've got six kids and...
- Six kids?
- Yeah, my wife and I we've
been married 24 years.
We have six children. Our
oldest is 21 down to eight.
So just like every
business person
or mom that's having to
work you have to balance
your home life, and
raising your kids,
and being a good husband,
and a good father
as well as your day job,
which my day job happens to
be governor of the state.
So it's always
busy, but it's fun.
It's an honorable lifetime
to serve your state where
your grandparents grew up.
And I pinched myself
thinking about my granddad
who had an
eighth-grade education.
He was a dairy farmer
in Skiatook, Oklahoma,
and now his grandson
is governor.
So I just wanna work my tail off
and make sure I leave my state
the best possible
state it can be
when I come back to
the private sector.
- You couldn't give anything
other than the kids.
So just, all right.
So you're in a pretty
functioning state
that seems like things
are going pretty well.
The woke stuff's not getting
in, you got business,
you got natural resources,
and all of those things.
Was there anything when you
came in as a businessman
to learn how government
operates and look at budgets,
and the way they spend
it, all that stuff,
were you just pulling
your hair out?
I'm trying to get something here
that might have frustrated
you along the way.
- Well, I mean, I don't
really want my legislature
to see this, but, you know,
working with the
legislature's been difficult.
You know, number one, I'm
trying to get school choice done
across the finish line.
I think that's the issue that
would turn our state around.
We want to empower parents,
not just the zip code that a
kid is happen to be born in,
or living at this time.
And I tell people all the time,
school choice should
not be for the rich,
it should be for everyone.
And these are kids in Oklahoma
and there's 700,000 kids,
let's make sure we educate
'em and we give them
the best opportunity, we've
put parents back in charge.
So trying to get that
across the finish line
is a goal of mine if
I'm fortunate enough.
- What kind of pushback
do you get on that?
Because I would imagine
in a red state, I mean,
there's so much momentum
behind that right now.
I can't imagine it's
too much, right?
- Well, we did not get
it across the finish line
this past session.
Hopefully, we can next year,
but really the rural folks that-
And they're right in the
fact that there aren't
a lot of the private schools,
but those aren't the
schools we're talking about.
A lot of it it's the inner city,
it's the large school districts
that are indoctrinating
the kids.
And then you have to try to-
You get parents
that are showing us
the books that they're teaching.
You can't micromanage every
single school district,
so let's inject competition,
let parents choose
where to send their
kids to school,
whether it's a Christian
school, or a Catholic school,
or a charter school, we need
more of that in our state.
So that's definitely a challenge
to try to get across the
finish line for our state.
Budget process, it's
got its own challenges.
I'm always trying to
hold our budgets flat.
And sometimes you fight
with some of the legislature
that wants to grow government,
to be quite honest with you.
And you know, you have to
really hold that in check
because we're always...
Nobody it seems like
fights for the taxpayer.
You've got all these lobbyists
and all these industries
will come in and hire folks
that advocate for
their industry,
but nobody advocates
for the taxpayer.
And that's my job,
that's what I tell 'em,
"Hey, I'm here fighting
for the taxpayer.
Let's hold budgets flat.
Let's make sure that we give
money back to the taxpayer
in the form of lower taxes."
- How much
coordination do you do
with some other red
state governors?
'Cause the event
that we were at,
it was kind of off
the record at first,
but of course the media gets
it and then they announced
everybody that was
there is what it is.
But you know, there are
obviously a bunch of other
red state governors
there, and it seemed like
you guys kind of talked
some of this stuff out.
I don't know, know
if it's official,
but you know, really
go back and forth on
it had a lot to do
with COVID lockdowns
and how maybe you would
do it going forward
if they tried to
pull anything else.
But is there a lot
of coordination on
that kind of stuff
or other issues?
- You know, I think there is.
I would call it a lot.
Republican Governors
Association,
I think is the
greatest organization
as far as political action
group in the country.
So I meet with those
governors probably
three or four times a year.
We all have each
other's cellphones,
so we'll text each other and
I'll call Billy in Tennessee,
you know, for example and say,
"Hey, what are you
doing on this?"
Or, "Hey, I saw something
in the paper about-
You know, Tennessee's
doing this.
Can you walk me through
your thought process?"
So we take ideas from
each other for sure.
And then we bounce, you know,
kind of what we're seeing in
our state with one another.
So it's a great collegial group
that we're able to meet
and kind of going through
the same thing together.
COVID was a gut
punch for all of us.
So we were all getting
hammered from the media
on, you know, demanding
it not locked down.
I was one of the only
governors in the country
that refused to do a mask
mandate, for example,
statewide and just got
hammered by the media.
So we've got a
liberal, you know,
fake news media here
in Oklahoma too.
- Ah, finally I got something.
I got something.
Okay. I don't know why that
gives me a little bit of joy.
It can't be that perfect there.
You know, I'm loving Florida
these days. All right.
Well, you're gonna appreciate
what I'm gonna do right now
because I am also a capitalist
and a free market guy.
So I'm gonna thank you for
joining me on the show,
and then I'm gonna ask
you one more question,
perhaps the most
important question
about Republican
leadership going forward.
We're gonna do that exclusively
for our subscribers.
So we're gonna wrap up this one
and go right over to
the locals community.
So governor Kevin Stitt, I
thank you for joining us.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
politics playlists.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.